no let's uh let's do alex we haven't
done alex in a minute right
all right alex it is oh this was
donald trump's
at the moment of truth and [ __ ] all over
everybody
i'm not enough cult for donald trump
[ __ ] him
[ __ ] his family all these people
all right see i shouldn't even be live
right now when are we going on the
satellite i love when he goes
i love when he up answered nobody appear
in this goddamn [ __ ] world
see not i'm [ __ ] pissed right now the
goddamn
[ __ ] liberal fascists censoring us
everywhere the last two days
we did an emergency [ __ ] 36-hour
broadcast
trying to stop this [ __ ] and you [ __ ]
liberal
pieces of [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
suck and support this [ __ ] you you
[ __ ] goddamn
degenerate [ __ ]
so i posted that a while back he seems
mad
i when i when i originally posed jim
edwards sent this to me and i
originally like him i thought it was
like a newer clip this is from when they
bombed syria or whatever
but it's still when i saw this clip the
other day i
felt it i felt every word that i was
like man like it's so relevant today
but god damn is that a great clip
and now they're blind
shouldn't be on there right now when the
[ __ ] are we going live
i can't do this [ __ ] trump and [ __ ]
these [ __ ] people
at a certain point man i'm sick of all
you [ __ ] liberals and me like you're
a bunch of cowardly [ __ ]
you're not americans what's going on
hey we're ready to go live okay he's
the quivering voice of that he's a
producer terrified that producer is one
of the funniest things i've ever heard
about
do you want to go live
i love that but it's so like honestly
every every word of that is true now
um so it worked i i really think the
worst thing alex ever did was
get into bed with trump alex should have
just stayed
don't trust the government guy he should
have stayed
the same way through trump that he's
been his whole career which is donald
trump
yeah his people are you know what i mean
he can't trust anybody's agenda
and he got so on to trump and lost
everything and he's lost his platform
he's lost his channel
he's losing listeners now he's losing
like he's lost a lot
over this and uh my favorite part of
that video though is [ __ ] donald trump
and [ __ ] his family i was like yes yes
[Laughter]
well this is a little more topical this
is uh okay this is from
last month not yet this is it's yuki
this is from last month um this is uh
him talking about what happened with
david knight by fraud
and they now want to start a fight but
like martin luther king or mahatma
gandhi
or who they were imitating jesus of
nazareth
we need to be non-violent at this point
because that's what exposes them as the
thugs they are
not given the images that they got at a
very limited level at the capitol
they intended to get citizens from all
over to militarily storm it
and to quote citizens arrest the
democrats that have been a hostage
situation
that would have allowed the 25th
amendment the president
and or impeach him and bring in total
tyranny thank god
the patriots fought and battled
with the antifa and the q
people that were totally under mind
control not all q people are bad a lot
of folks get into it because it's fun
like an easter egg hunter whatever a
treasure hunt
but a lot of folks don't get the larger
picture of how they're using augmented
reality online
to manipulate you in the real world now
it's a globalist operation
remember trump was invincible couldn't
be beat jeff sessions was great hillary
was in gitmo
uh bill barr was great none of it was
true folks but they know you want good
news
i could make stuff up and have it super
viral all day that was something about
david knight and i really liked david
he could do whatever he wanted he asked
me to hire his second son
uh you basically to run a website for
them just to promote his stuff alone
and he didn't like the cue stuff
and we'd have a few guests on here and
there that would kind of promote that
and then he would say jones is having
these people on i
and i'm like i don't agree with what
those people are saying
and then he's like well i'm going to
quit i mean i can't be around this i'm
going to get fired
is this about that john what's his face
guy i'm not really sure
because there was a clip that adam green
posted on um
on twitter and um you know his ankle is
spoiler alert um but
he posted a clip of this john something
or other guy who's a q and on dude
and he basically like admitted live on
infowars like
yeah we were putting stuff out because
we needed you guys to get that message
out but it was like basically admitting
that he's full of [ __ ] and
like i think i'm wondering because that
is i forget the guy's name i'm sure
somebody in the chat
can can um probably tell me who the guy
is john p
peacenik uh steve p nick no that's the
guy it's not john
steve steve peacenik that that's the guy
sorry it's not wasn't jon
so this steve guy kept going on infowars
and pushing cue [ __ ]
and he was doing a lot of the kraken
stuff and you know doing a lot of that
even though most of the infowars people
were kind of like
yeah i don't whatever but alex was
letting this guy on and then
it was like a thing where the guy went
on to
infowars again and he goes yeah i
basically like more or less i used you
guys
to create a you know to create some hype
because we needed a
pressure and it's like like that guy is
such a
scumbag q anon grifter
and he was going on there doing that
[ __ ] and that makes sense if
cause david knight does strike me as a
guy that would go no this
is [ __ ] like you know are are we or
are we not the good guys like or do we
need to sell dick pills like
i i kind of believe a certain angle i i
do believe that david knight would be
out of all the guys at infowars
he'd be the one that's like this is
stupid why are we giving this guy air
time so
i don't know yeah um
and so david knight
according to what alex is saying was
sick of all the cue stuff
now look maybe alex had these people on
and he didn't believe them and he just
alex
to his credit will pretty much just have
anybody on um
but i have a feeling that david knight
thing was more than just the q stuff
right um maybe i don't know
i mean it's it's like look it's it's
like any relationship that ends
you know there's there's always like the
thing that made the relationship
end potential potential i don't know
just letting you know i know i just hate
names um
no they you got the worst [ __ ] names
let's have the worst [ __ ] names
mm-hmm
it's like every time you got to talk to
bali song you like make some artwork and
you got a paypal and we're like i don't
even know how your money works
oh my god and then when you pay him like
his paypal is like 700 and 500
700 characters yeah and then i gotta pay
like it gets to convert the us dollar
into like
mushnik's or whatever the [ __ ] you
people have over there stop it
stop mushnix whatever what are much
people suck i hate polish people
anyway you [ __ ] what you've done your
wins and you z's and your seas and your
wise
if i ever [ __ ] see any of you in the
street i'm gonna bury my fist in your
bread basket
um but back to the thing
it's like the end of any relationship
where
you um you have like people go like oh
they broke up because you cheated on her
and then it's like
oh okay that's the reason they broke up
but then you really find out like
the cheating was also part of like just
them hating each other and they were
already fighting and
he you know he's getting [ __ ] nagged
every day about he said he was gonna
clean out the garage and
like there's there's always all of these
elements you're not making enough money
so and so is not working hard at like
and then when the cheating happens like
oh they broke up because you cheated you
go oh
okay open and shut case but you go well
no that relationship was already
like you know two out of four of the
engines already blew
out and it was already losing altitude
so it wasn't the cheap the cheating blew
up the plane
the plane was going to hit the ocean
anyway right so i'm sure there were
other factors but i do think that
part of it was the q stuff and and it is
true like
you know like if if you start
making a big [ __ ] stink about the q
stuff every day
it's going to add to the like jesus
christ [ __ ] david guy again with this
[ __ ] like
you know if he wants to be the boss tell
him to [ __ ] start his own company and
you know
like all that [ __ ] will start to fester
and then i'm sure it was just i'm sure
alex looked at the books at the end of
the year and was like
you know we could probably just not have
david knight like we could afford that
i'm being censored and that's what hurts
is i never censored him he took
what i would say on air if i disagree
with him as censorship
and it was so weird i've even seen some
of his shows where he goes censorship
was bad over there i knew i'd be let go
soon
in the name of jesus christ and all my
children ever since or david knight he's
a liar
he made that up on air and i see him
like a devil on his show now
just he all envious hateful deviling up
there
said in the name of jesus i rebuke you
david knight you're a liar
i never censored you and i'm not with
you and you know that and that's why i
let him go
because he hated me and he hated
infowars and he told me
in his studio that he didn't want me on
his show and he was ashamed of us
well good go away from us but
i didn't think this was gonna get that
[ __ ]
i didn't think that was gonna get that
[ __ ]
[Music]
that was heated and personal and i
didn't see this
i i saw some stuff coming out eventually
about this but i did not expect
this to just
[Music]
i could probably get david on the show
you want me to try
yeah why not i'll get him we'll talk to
him i could you know i kind of believe
alex on this
i i do think this is a situation where
both people kind of think they're right
i think this is a situation where
honestly if you talk to both guys
they probably would both have valid
points you know
but that last part feels like alex
really feels like david knight's
straight up lying about him like that's
i don't think alex is you're right i
agree with you i think both people
believe they're telling the truth
is this one this is one of those
situations where depending on which way
they see it they both believe that they
are telling the truth that they are the
ones that are
um i don't think anyone's trying to be
deceitful i think both people are
butting heads here i'll try to get david
on
um i could try to get alex on again too
i don't know if he's going to want to
talk about the david knight stuff but
you know what we could just get harrison
smith he's boring he'll tell us
a lot of swords was he around
is there isn't even around i haven't i
haven't seen him around in a while
probably like like hiding in his room
with his headphones on like you do when
your parents are like abusive and
fighting
he like went in his room and like
[ __ ] put his headphones on and was
like rocking out
like macaulay talking at the beginning
of the black and white video yeah
i would guess that harrison went up in
his room while his parents were fighting
put headphones on and listen to like
some some real [ __ ] too like sunny day
real estate
oh no no no come on please don't tell me
stuff like that
you want to like you're just all sad
uh it says your david knight doesn't
like talking about it he addressed it on
twitter a few times and twice on his new
show
well then it sounds like he doesn't mind
talking about it yeah so it's like it
sounds like he's actually been doing a
good job of talking about it
mr demon money says harrison smith was
at the snack machine trying to be
invisible
oh and it's yeah of course it's the day
that you got it you have one of those
kind of dollars and you're like
son of a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know what i'm not that hungry i
don't care he just drops the dollar on
the fence
ten minutes folding it to get it perfect
puts it in and then it goes it goes in
and out even less
you ever do that where you get the bill
even better and put it in and then it
goes
and you're like it's even better than it
was
[ __ ] oh no you [ __ ] a man that's all
i'm thinking
of poor harrison oh [ __ ] by the way and
you know the vending machines suck at
him for wars because it's all infowars
products
of course bone broth i just need to get
some [ __ ]
super male vitality get me pumped hey
alex can we have like maybe
one spot in the machine that's like
snickers i don't know reese's peanut
butter cup
snickers turn you're gay yeah i'm not
having that globalist candy in my place
make our own candy have some bone broth
he just throws [ __ ] bone broth at his
head we're coming out with our own ice
cream bars harrison that's right
unfortunately i lost a fortune because i
already had a bunch shipped out with
david knight's face on it
son of a [ __ ] make sure to listen to
david knight's new show night wave
spell with a k it's on it i also
invested in a bunch of ice cream bars
with trump's face on it i was really
really hopeful we were going to win now
i've just got a boxing gear still ice
cream
i think if we alter them enough we can
make them look like biden i'm gonna send
them back tell them to
i don't know add some hair make them
less orange and less pedophilia
even worse that david knight wants he
makes harrison smith grow a beard
harrison grow a beard and gain 20 pounds
harrison grow a beard it better be
better than crowders
[Laughter]
all right alex uh someone send this clip
to harrison please i want him to know
we're talking about him
uh
poor david knight